i wasn't planning at all i wasn't
planning to make the last one but i saw
mr feast he did a mr beast video and my
curiosity just
i got to watch this i got it you got to
i got i watched it i got it so is he
making fun of mr beast or is he
i don't know that's a ballsy thing to do
it's got more dislikes than normal so
i'm like damn all right dorman maybe uh
you know he's got some balls you better
watch out because he may make a
pewdiepie video or something yeah yeah
what would he do
he'll do
he'll have me outside and then a bunch
of fans run up and they'll be like hey
can we take a shot no no and then you
lose all your subscribers and then they
get all your subscribers and then you
regret it
he then became completely irrelevant
washed up youtuber if only
that's always them
what does it come when they speak over
anyway let's watch this video
yeah okay i'm ready guys today we're
gonna buy one more okay
and literally give them all away this is
what we made fun of thar men doing if
you guys want to win a brand new ps5 all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel subscribe to facebook's channel
and then leave a comment i can't believe
people are still doing [ __ ] giveaways
holy [ __ ] it's so annoying
stop this [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm so tired of
it
10 years of youtube people are still
like buying subs where they [ __ ] you
can't you can't steal our material
darmian what is this no no see that's
what was it uh some someone who one of
the guys said it that we were like oh
you don't like mr beast because yeah
giveaway yeah it's a different thing
this is a completely different thing
than like subscribe and follow us on
everything and we may give you a
playstation or something
versus where mr beast's content is
the giving the stuff away right it gives
away all kinds of stuff it's
it is different and that's what makes
his uh mysteries videos actually
entertaining by the fact to give his way
but to be fair i gotta say though it is
kind of like he does angle it a little
bit like oh subscribe to me
and you know you could win something
yeah yeah that's still there he still
does that here right yeah
but
are you ain't no mr beast you better
watch out you better watch out he's not
gonna plant a tree in your name okay nah
let's watch video we're not calling out
anyone we love darmian on this channel
we love mr beast on this channel we love
face drug on this channel oh we love
everybody everybody we're just making
jokes for the content it's fine we love
everyone nothing but love
actors
love them those shorts that guys are
wearing
[Music]
i can't believe it's you we're big fans
of your youtube channel thank you so
much guys but let's ask you the
important question
are you subscribed
can't you see we're recording here he's
going to buzz up in the middle of it
dude he's totally calling out mr beef
i have this shirt actually this shirt
that seems weird
i got it
the black and like little gray pokey
daddy shirt he's got i'm cool the plaid
shirt no no no the t-shirt that guy's
wearing like the mystic feast uh i have
the exact same shirt i think it might be
a v-neck though version
i'm pretty sure yeah see what's going on
let's pull those phones out what do you
think bets you got bets i got 10 on him
you got 10 on this all right uh that's
the broke friend yep yep and you are not
subscribed you got exposed i thought oh
my god shaming him my friend's guy how
dare you not be surprised
are they actually going to call mr reese
out for him doing this as a meme i don't
know i i would love that that would make
him very happy
is it
why would he do this
is this what actually like you're not
subscribed called out boo you suck so
then everyone that's not subscribed gets
me
he's that he he does this but he does it
in a funny way not like oh you [ __ ]
idiot i usually give some stuff anyway
so it's kind of weird but
yeah
congratulations now you get to pick
between this ps5 or
all the money
but wait a minute and they just they
were just randomly standing around with
the ps5 in case someone shows up
what
i still don't have one all right i still
don't have one you still don't have a
ps5 no
no not gonna get like an australian one
awful oh i don't know
take the ps5 that way we could both play
fine yeah i'll take the ps5 you're sure
you want the ps5 absolutely all right
fish give her the ps5 all right
congratulations yeah fish and now see
it's a good thing that she picked the
ps5 because i literally have
one dollar
oh my god
and the playstation 5 is actually filled
with goo
that box has been opened
it's refurbished from gamestop sorry you
lose
this is i never expected to see this on
dartmouth
i love you so much
you're the best have a good day
now guys we only need 99 more ps5s to go
let's get it boys
where's this going well he gets kicked
out of a store
oh my god
this guy's the hater he's about to kick
him out and regret it ah because he
could have gotten 95 because
playstations if mr feast was actually mr
beast he would have had one of his
people call ahead of time and yeah they
wouldn't definitely
yeah they would definitely do that 99
ps5s are fine and we're going to give
them all away hey hey you kids can't
film inside this store
uh is joey here
i missed her feast my team called early
it's joey here
joey mama joe mama
i didn't call in okay okay i'll take it
now get that camera out of here i said
no filming allowed okay man
hey we're gonna cut
um
handler you called before right yeah
handler instead of chandler what are
they doing
[ __ ] handling what are you doing
we spoke with joey he said it was cool
if he filmed he knows that we're coming
right fish yeah we just came here to buy
all your ps5s but
there should be more here though if we
could just talk to joey then he's not
here right now and he didn't mention
anything about a feast or a fish coming
down here oh [ __ ]
are you the owner no
joey is but i'm the manager so when he's
not here i'm in charge
all right i can drop a serious amount of
cash in here can we film as long as we
don't get you in it
fine but just so you know i'm keeping a
close eye on you kids what yeah you kids
who talks like this what is happening
what am i watching what is happening
well i don't know what to say no i don't
get it the bad guys
often are you know who's the best they
can't be who's the bad guy i don't get
it is it mr fees is it him i don't i'm
so confused you see this guy's eyebrows
his bald head he's definitely supposed
to be the bad guy but these darn kids
are ruining his business by trying to
buy all the ps5s
i'm always the worst owner ever because
they even tell anybody yeah that's
joey's fault
all right well we're going to try that
again we're rolling yeah all right here
we go what's up guys i know we said
we're going to buy all these ps5s but
now i'm just kind of thinking we should
buy the whole store wait what no i'm
being dead serious because of this video
right here you guys loved it so much
when we bought a store so might as well
do it again right
heck yeah awesome right handler go grab
a couple of those carts man on it what
about the ps5 oh don't worry we're still
gonna get those too
ready
why is this so awkward i'm so weirded
out by this i like the lace potato chips
next to the
routers i don't know what that is yeah
gonna get a couple you know hey gamers
you know you got your routers you better
get your chips
doritos the mountain dews on the other
side
[Music]
was that a razor i'm so
lost on this i have no idea what's gonna
happen he's he's like you know what
that guy gave me some lips so we're now
we're buying the whole store
yeah
well let's show them filling things up
boys all right well since we're gonna be
buying everything in the store i might
as well just start grabbing stuff yeah
wait these are over a hundred dollars
each what they're that expensive oh no
i'm gonna go broke
whose idea was this anyways
yours fair point
maybe the nice manager's gonna give us a
discount right whoa whoa stop recording
you stop recording
stop recording
stop recording right now this is
i'm on edge watching this entire video
because i don't know what the [ __ ]
gonna happen
yeah
you seem to understand it though i'm i'm
lost i don't get it i don't i'm just
trying to make stuff up and okay good
because something's gonna happen and
it's gonna it's gonna come together
eventually all right it's a dharma video
you know you know you think i'm giving
you a discount hey look man i was just
kidding i'm happy to pay full price for
everything how do you plan on doing that
do your parents even know you're racking
out their credit cards hey that's mr
feast he doesn't need to use your
parents
i'm paying for it i don't know if you
ever heard of youtube but you see i i've
seen all the videos where you kids prank
people for views so don't think i'm
falling for that
no that's not what we do at all yeah
he's serious when he says he's gonna buy
out your entire store just trust him
yeah just be [ __ ] thankful
huh just smile and be happy that he's
buying out your entire store do you know
do you not know this is mr b's priest
he's not watching beast you should be
battling money in his presence yeah you
assume he's wasting his pain money no
he's making his own money
all right
trust him
i'm not trusting some young pranksters
you boys listen here this store has been
struggling enough ever since that game
shop opened up across the street
i don't need you all man that makes no
sense for the freaking game shop god
dang it we're struggling he's just
trying to protect the business yeah by
not selling anything we're literally
trying to do the opposite i want to buy
everything in your store i mean how much
does this stuff cost yeah right like you
could even afford a fraction of what's
in this store oh you kids came in here
saying you want to buy video games buy
the games and leave i don't need any
more trouble wait so you set your store
struggling you want to buy literally
everything in here but you don't want to
get your man out of fish yeah
how's that gonna help yeah you're so
completely loud inventory customers will
come in they'll be like all right guess
there's nothing in this store never come
back a hair again hey i mean i could see
this man's point of view you know these
young
pranksters coming in like look at these
guys
yeah
like look at this guy's pocket what is
this it was all over that
mom have to sew that back up for me or
something i can't afford everything in
the store please struggle enough
game spot opened up or whatever you said
i i think that if there was an actual
angle here it would have been the fact
that this is a hardworking man trying to
run his business he's struggling and
then some youtube channel just comes in
i know he doesn't do this but i'm just
saying for the angle of the video uh
some youtube challenges coming in trying
to get views or whatever and using him
and his business as a prop for charity
or or uh uh not charity i think he's
right to be skeptical this whole
situation but it's
it's kind of demeaning in a sense
you don't want our help we're gonna buy
your whole store we're rich
don't want our help you see what i mean
yeah i get you i understand yeah yeah
okay all right
they got a good point this could solve a
lot of your problems man i don't know
who you kids think you're fooling
either by the game stations or get out
game stations look we don't want any
issues this is all you have because i
was hoping to buy a lot more uh we got
more in the back but i'm gonna need to
see how you're paying for these first
sure it's not a problem here you can uh
you put it on this card
mr feast
do you really expect me to believe
that's your real name oh my god they
just ring it up holy [ __ ] is my
corporation my real name
like you're even old enough to start a
chord oh my god
but this is this is like a poor mr beast
thing does this happen
that's the angle okay
all right
young kids please
no one takes me serious when i want to
buy out their whole store this is such a
struggle i'm trying to buy out the whole
store and he won't let me
wow oh no
no know i guess i'll just say that i did
and you know
not actually do it and still make the
video mr beast don't fake his videos ken
how dare you i'm not saying that mr
beast fakes videos you just did but i'm
saying mr feast might okay
yeah he definitely would look at him i
should have went with my gut on this one
and kicked you kids out a lot sooner
he's not lying you can check out our
youtube i've seen enough
i need all of you to get out are you
sure man we're about to drop a serious
amount of money in here get out say that
already get out are you serious man like
we're gonna this this is you okay
money
bam bam we're gonna drop it so hard like
listen up dude come on mr peace you
never heard of these we come back when
you got some cash can we give you money
we're trying to save your business
that's what we're doing here we're
saving your ass dude just call up joey
come on we're gonna buy so many
playstations fives you're gonna be able
to retire my dude yeah why don't they
just say that why don't you just call
joey how about that just
call the owner
uh
right
well they call him like hey man you know
if they had joey's cell numbers they
could let them know they're coming or
something like that no anyway yeah any
problems we're going all right let's go
boys
that didn't go exactly as planned did it
what are we gonna do now can we get some
food i'm getting hungry fish you're
always hungry
[Laughter]
that's gonna tie in in the end ken it's
small details
chekhov's gun style of storytelling you
know right right right stuff to give
away i'm gonna tie it yeah the whole
point that i was talking about maybe we
can get some stuff there nice
go buy the game shop out it's the mr
beast video behind the game stops mr
beast actually has the video you know
buying out yeah i know
and so now they're going to the game
shop which is the parody of the gamestop
it all lines up anyway art imitates life
okay that's what's happening here when
you guys call that
on it sweet let's go guys
hey vic
hey joey how's it going oh joey's gonna
be mad
dang joey look at that hair let's do
bills we got
well
hopefully things turn around soon well
you need to fire that guy he's a
terrible salesman
come on
look i feel like they have a lot of um a
lot of theft in the store because all
these phones are just sitting out
yeah
you could just grab them all in one
swoop i got a call from mr feast and his
friends they said they might stop by
today
i i didn't think it was real at first
but what
those youtube pranksters no they're not
youtube pranksters they run one of the
largest youtube channels in the world
and they give away millions of dollars
they do
yeah
yeah they can really change our lives
why
they didn't happen to stop by today
kids came down here and
i thought they were scamming us
i kicked them out you did what
why did i show up when they got here
because it could have saved us it seemed
to be very important but you know i
showed up to be late
let's go don't worry about the stories
could have been our police section five
surviving okay well let me help you with
that though all right thanks have you
seen that there they are let's go
oh they'll see them get them get their
money joey the owner of the shop across
the street i believe we talked on the
phone earlier
first off i just want to say i am so
sorry for how my manager treated you i
didn't know get this on camera get this
on camera i didn't know how many
subscribers you had i am how did i know
how rich you guys are yeah
i feel so fully listen
if you maybe you could give me a shout
out that would mean the world to me my
dudes
everything changes now that i know how
wealthy you are
i now respect you and your demeanor feel
terrible for everything i said
it's fine don't worry about it we were
actually able to get all our ps5 so oh
man
you shopping at our store would have
literally saved us
yeah maybe in the future you could
give us another chance
what do you think handler
what do you think
i don't think so
mr feast ain't no pushover
sorry guys i mean let's be real if i
would have bought your entire store you
guys would have been bottom up in a
couple months anyway so you know
maybe you should change
some things about your marketing you
know maybe yeah you guys will give us
advice you can teach fish to fish but
you can't teach man how to fish
it all makes sense now boom
i understand
sorry again about everything
well what i meant to say was uh
just kidding future when i could just
about your whole store right now
oh my god
thank you so much
yeah two videos in one day let's do it
we're gonna need a bigger truck
[Applause]
oh mr feast you're the best
what's up guys and welcome back i'm
standing here with my good friend joey
and he gets a chance she's getting ten
thousand dollars in cash or this key
that goes with something expensive now
joe the only catch is you only have 10
seconds to choose between the two and
the countdown starts right now
the house
[Applause]
now you just gave up 10 000 in cash for
a key that you don't know what it goes
to
i just had to go with my gut all right
well let's see if you've got this all
right guys you guys bought everything in
my store
i marked up double price just for you so
i'm rich
all right joe you can open your eyes now
this is gonna be this is gonna hit hard
there's gonna be the emotional [ __ ] i
don't know if i'm really kidding point i
guess uh i'm gonna cry
right
what's this
open it
it's a piece of paper
no
wait is this
yeah i know you were a little bit behind
on rent so i went ahead and bought the
whole building so you don't have to
worry about paying anymore
my god are jesus christ yeah i guess how
much it costs though a lot more than 10
grand yeah a lot more than 10 grand it
actually costs 560
i gotta say that so we could put that in
the title
i thought he was going to buy my house
and i was about to go through the things
this struggling businessman just bought
him a house and now he has to pay all
the taxes on that
[Laughter]
we got to grow people's lives doing that
so much yeah you're welcome man oh do
you have anything you want to say to the
fans yeah make sure you subscribe to mr
feast
welcome to the behind the scenes well
what's the point of this i'm so confused
all right i don't know i loved it
darmian great video smash like subscribe
i have so many thoughts i'm so lost with
the [ __ ] mr bc commented on it
yeah
great video enjoyed it liked man maybe
maybe shoot i mean mr mr beast is
freaking tearing up youtube maybe i need
to be like
a lot of other channels and start trying
to emulate what he's doing
i got some money i can start giving some
stuff away i i can't blame them for
doing it because clearly like when
you're young money
seems like such an important thing yeah
or like it's more at least
it's kind of like uh
this reminds me of that meme where like
someone did the math wrong and thought
that elon musk could like pay for
everyone a million dollar or something
like that because
the difference between a billion and a
million
why can't mr peace just pay everyone he
has so much money
give everyone a little bit of money mr
beast come on i mean look i mean shoot
mr bass was giving away money when he
didn't like i i mean that's been like
his thing like forever right and i
always wondered i was like how's he
doing this where's he getting this money
at what the heck but now it's all he's
got like freaking 10 channels he's got a
lot of channels
more subscribers than i have in my
entire life you know it's you're racking
up now you can bob mr beast and island
no don't i don't want it actually don't
do that
you're on miss beast by your house cam
just say it come on man no
you're gonna buy me a house remember to
make a video about it it's fun
maybe i should do like mr b's i realized
i'm making more money than i need
dude we've already talked about uh the
opposite mr beast you use your money to
make people miserable
i love that idea
we buy out all the chandlers i got
chandler
carl what get over here how much i got
to pay for carl to come over here
[Laughter]
i'm just now i'm waiting for the
collaboration with us guys to make a
video with you sometime soon
what was the
lesson never underestimate mr beast
basically i think
don't be a boomer
don't think everyone's trying to scam
you save your failing business choose
the key yeah
if it's a beast comes to your store you
better be stocked up on playstation 5.
that's right that's what i got out of
this and that was kind of good we didn't
have like it was a parody we didn't have
a whole lot to just rip on and make fun
of a bunch of stuff that was a
quality it was great best video good job
all right good job check out darm man my
new favorite channel subscribe all love
this is this is for you darmian
yeah and uh check out ken i feel bad yes
he has no subscribers he's kind of sad
if i get 5 million subscribers by the
end of september i'll share with my
brows how about that no don't do that
i don't want to see that wait i was just
pooping in the shower what was i
supposed to do
i don't know we'll we'll work on it okay
thank you
eat a half a toilet paper roll dude i
can't wait to get more comments on my
videos being like all you do is write
beauty plays coattails and i'm like
yes
bro if you did you would have had at
least five million subs by now i feel
like i know right so i'm kind of late to
the party on that finally it's taken me
nine years to come around
all right thanks for watching guys see
you in the next one
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers are
emotions memes our emotions
express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this